so next up we have Bettina Kosta talking
about does this algorithm have a soul hi
everyone today I'm going to answer the
question does this algorithm have a soul
so the first star let me probably
introduce myself my name is Bettina but
you can call me Tina or the girl from
Brazil and I am a software engineer at
ThoughtWorks and also volunteering
projects like jungle girls and afro
Python that is basically jungle girls
but for the black community I'm also a
data science student and I'm a huge
introvert so I don't usually talk much
but if you wanted me want to learn me
out of my cage just bring up some movie
subject and I would never shut up again
so machine learning what we've been
talking a lot about the last three days
society always have search for ways to
improve itself and machine learning is
just one of the ways that we found and a
lot of good things have come from
machine learning one example one example
is in Singapore the healthcare providers
they use machine learning to offer more
customized and better treatments for its
patients and better plans for them and
also in Brazil we have this project
called Operation Serenata jamol that is
an open project that
has job the the the goal of make
politicians accountable for their use
and pull it money and hopefully spread
that information in a friendly way so
people can be aware of where their money
is being spent and with such good things
being done with machine learning a
natural way that we went to is what if
we could and bias to data that's a huge
problem that we as human beings face
every single day we the pairs ourselves
with some with some prejudice situation
in the streets in the judicial system
hiring process loan process we we have
the rules waiting often more on on the
weaker side in Brazil for example a guy
a black guy was arrested during a
protest protest carrying a a bleach
bottle and was sentenced to five years
in jail while rich white guys that
literally kill their wives are sent to
much less and sometimes not even get to
jail so what why we keep delivering the
powerful decisions to people they are
often full of bias what if we could pass
that power of decisions to algorithms
that are basically bites and cold they
they don't have any type of bias they
are strictly math but
is that actually true well I think most
of you are already aware of this case
but algorithms for producing hasted his
divisible are commonly used in in courts
to calculate the risk of defendant to
commit a crime again technically these
algorithms would be more accurate and
with contain less bias then if they were
this decision were made by human beings
but a few years ago Pro Publica research
discovered that that is not often true
when the algorithm get it get it gets it
right it's often okay but when it gets
wrong it is more likely to to wrongly
label black defendants as more likely to
commit a crime than wise white
defendants that twice more likely to
wrong to made a mistake to black people
side
but okay why why that where that happens
we had this algorithm to help us to come
back to fight against bias in our
society but it was kind of doing it
doing exactly the opposite well do this
algorithm was based on a set of
questions one hundred three or five
three seven questions that were answered
or by the defendant himself or by
criminal records and it's important to
say that race was not among these
questions but one of the three examples
of those questions were how many of her
friends / acquittance were taking drugs
illegally was one of your parents ever
sent to jail or prison how often did you
get in fights at school at first look
there he seems like very very good
questions actually and doesn't seem to
have anything wrong with them but once
you take a closer look and that you
understand that a large part of the
people who are currently in jail in the
United States are black or Hispanic we
kind of see where those questions are
leading
when it come to crime
predicting algorithms this type of our
ins has the goal to help police police
offers officers and police department to
figure out what are places there are
places and neighborhoods who are more
likely to have crimes happen in a
current time period and the problem with
this kind of algorithms is that they can
easily generate a feedback loop the most
you you are you train your algorithm
with data with data based on arrests
made in certain neighborhoods it's very
easy to kind of re reinforce some status
that is already established so we have a
place where a lot of arrests are
happening and then you send more police
to this place and then maras continue
happens and you don't know how much this
is accurate and how much is your average
house earnest because let's think of
this way you are a police officer and
you know that that neighborhood is going
to happen a crime eventually that's what
you were told something is going to
happen so you you kind of get more
likely to be more aggressive in time of
making arrests because you know
something is going to happen here
okay but some of you might be thinking
well I'm not working with crime
predicting Algar it's not working with
cart algorithms like I'm just some
machine learning expert but I don't
actually work with any of this I don't
intend to get arrested anytime soon so
others exactly has to do with me so I'm
going to try to bring this a little
closer to home when you talk about
facial recognition there's a lot of
police departments using this type of
technology and that's a natural movement
once we have cameras all over the place
these days so there's nothing wrong with
them using it the problem is that three
of the bigger companies that work with
this type of technology especially on
gender recognition algorithms and photos
they are pretty accurate when it's about
recognizing white men they have a 99% of
accuracy but when is about correctly
identifying dark-skinned women they have
only a 35% of accuracy so this makes
makes highly likely that a black woman
will be wrongly identified by facial
recognition technology that's being used
by the police silver lining here is that
IBM Microsoft they have already
acknowledged that problem and retrain
their algorithms so it's getting better
and something I believe even closer to
us are certain genes research made by
the University of Washington and
Maryland revealed a bias in google image
research when when regarding job and
career search for men and women
sometimes during the research when you
are looking for authors and
telemarketing professionals that are -
professionals they're basically 50/50
for men and women United States the the
risk the search results for Google image
were like 25% of women for author and
64% for telemarketing but besides that
results Mardin then half of the the
searches were practically equal with
only 5% of difference between the actual
scenario and the one showed by Google
image but when we you analyze the kind
of image that was being displayed and
how men and women looked like in those
images the the story is very very very
different when search for women
professionals the images that are more
likely to appear are more sexy and
joking and not really professional
images that was research made in 2013
and as well we have improved a lot since
there but if you if today you look for
like Latin girls
or Asian girls in Google image you see
that we still have a long way to go
ones about search and jeans okay so
after everything that I just spoke here
we you may think okay we're doomed
there's nothing else to be done let's
throw our computers out of the window
delete our AWS account you know what too
late
Skynet became self-aware and we are
going to die that's not the message that
I wanna pass today so let's go back a
little take a deep breath and see what
exactly we can do as machine learning
experts and human beings to go against
this tendency and I'm going to talk more
about things that we can do more as
human beings are not more like a
technical approach first of all we have
to acknowledge the problem we have to
acknowledge that algorithm bias is a
thing it has happened and the moment
that I train a machine learning
algorithm that is a possibility
and if I made an algorithm that has any
racial bias gender bias it is okay as
long as I recognize that okay my
algorithm has that problem and I have to
do something to fix it if we don't
recognize the the problem there's not
much we can do about it and the the
company responsible for a compass and
Pratt poo they all at some point denied
that there's anything wrong with their
algorithms
once we acknowledge the problem it's
important also spread the problem
because most of data data experts and
everyone in this room we we recognize
that there the algorithm bias is a thing
but when we go outside our tech bubble
we see that people had a blind faith in
algorithms and machines if if an
algorithm is saying something it has to
be true if you're following your GPS and
it sends you to some route it has to be
right
you know who am I to question the
machine
thank you an effort give me the example
and that's really dangerous because we
have to acknowledge the power that we
have to other people that are believing
blindly and the work that we are doing
that it is correct
another thing is that we shouldn't have
black boxes the compass algorithm the
pred collaboration they are all
preparatory and it's very hard for us to
see how it's really working and why
exactly is presenting these results and
people lives are being changed by the
algorithm so they should have the right
to see how it works that the matters
they're not going to understand of it is
too complex you can have it lock it away
in a black box that no one can access
and no one can see what's going on
another important thing is to change the
status quo when regarding the deep red
pole the crime prediction one we have
these result bias or not that
neighborhood
it's more violence is going to occur
more crime there so we can change more
police there to make more arrests or we
can try to figure out why the
neighborhood it's so dangerous what is
happening there and what we can do to
make it not be dangerous anymore maybe
believe public policy is more education
more culture instead to send our police
there to just keep things the way they
are and regarding the facial recognition
algorithms it was very accurate
recognizing white men maybe because the
most part of the developing team are
cisgender white man maybe if you have a
more diverse team working on that that
wouldn't be an issue
and the last one and maybe the more hard
the harder one is be better like there's
been what a hundred years since women
can vote in the United States two
hundred years ago in my country is late
as Lavery was still the thing that we
have a huge history of hate behind us
who have years and years and years of
data based on prejudice and hate and
honestly right now we are not exactly
our in our best moment for example in my
country we just elected a guy who say to
his colleague inside of a Congress that
he wouldn't rape her because she didn't
deserve it and if we don't become better
human beings we won't generate data that
is without bias and we will forever have
this problem
and I'm I'm not exactly not miss I don't
think that we will end prejudice forever
I think it's in our nature have some
kind of prejudice against people who are
different but I hope that in the future
our algorithms would be biased again
people who like cilantro than people who
have different sexual orientations or a
different skin color so getting back to
our main questions do algorithms have
souls yes they have they have souls they
are designed by us and that project
everything that we are and we can use
that to try to change the status quo
established today in our society or we
can use to hide it behind this and say
it isn't part impartial and use just to
keep things as they are and that's it
thank you very much thank you any
questions
hi a good presentation I had a question
there was one slide where you talked
about thirty-four percent error rate
difference as far as official
recognition what do you think were I
guess the contributing parts to it now
mind you it's kind of a bit of a
two-part question because with facial
working with algorithms or even models
you know whatever you input is really
dependent on what what your output is
actually depends heavily on what you're
actually input you know so like say for
instance with you know the flaws in the
output that's actually coming out from
different algorithms you know that you
could easily go to labor economics and
look at you know earlier models or even
look at IT development research where
you know one can defend that higher GDP
is a significant factor to one country
becoming going into war so sometimes it
depends on what they're actually
inputting do you think that's the case
with facial recognition that is the case
it kind of happens with another type of
technologies like we have a group of
people that sometimes don't have contact
with diversity they are developing that
so maybe when they trained their data
said they didn't actually care about
asserting a lot of dark-skinned and
woman in it
for example me banned this in there I'm
using for I don't know if they still
have this problems but for a time it
didn't work to get the heart beating for
very dark-skinned people because you you
you didn't test that because it's not
senior in your regular environment so
you don't actually think about it and if
I answer your question
hi thank you for the wonderful talk my
first question is that a lot of the
examples a cheese were us-based I want
to know if you know of any cases of that
have been exposed of some algorithmic
systems that have unfair results in in
Brazil because Brazil Brazil has were
race and race and Brazil is much
different than how race operates in the
US so I'm interested in that and then a
follow-up question is what are ways that
machine learning efforts and data
scientists can help uncover unfairness
and maybe if they suspect it what are
some strategies that maybe that you
would give for looking into particular
systems or api's or whatnot so the first
question yes we we are starting to to
use algorithms to hiring process and we
have Martin half of the population in
Brazil is black and that often does not
reflect in most of the companies and
there are companies starting to offer
the service of Oh hire the we can find
the best person for your tired based on
successful profile and when this
movement started it was basically that
most of these sets of profiles were
recommended white man and so yeah we're
starting to to have this kind of problem
in Brazil the the only example that I
know we
in hiring hire algorithms but yeah we
are having this problem right now but
there's there's a lot of not a lot of
people but there are some people may be
making researchers to ensure that they
can minimize the effects of it sometimes
the algorithm accuracy is not that good
when you have a fair algorithm and the
second questions I actually don't know I
don't I don't have knowledge of how we
can fight this
technically in true cold cold cold and
how to better train our algorithms but
something I truly believe that can help
is have more diverse teams that is
especially in Brazil I'm not sure how is
the scenario here in the United States
but it's a huge problem I've worked in
several places and only in the last
place that I'm working I have a black
colleague I spend a lot of time without
working with women for example so I
think when we start having more
diversity we kind of have different
looks of what is fair and what's not
fair and we can properly access these
problems in our algorithms no more
questions
thank you very much for your talk so I
want to give just an example I work for
GlaxoSmithKline jsk and we have GSK
Global Health as part of our company
because we know that the science tells
us when we put a vaccine out
it has 96% effectivity on the US
population and 75 on the Brazilian
population for example okay so we we
know that the problem exists so what we
try to do is to make something so we
have a separate department that makes
something that it has the same effective
'ti in other population as well my my
question and also my suggestion would be
would it be fair if us as data
scientists or machine learning
scientists or whatever pushes push
things a little bit like we skew the
algorithm a little bit because we know
that the data is unfair it will always
be unfair like when Alex showed this
morning that the word captain is
associated with male is because of
course captain is a military term and
for the past centuries militaries always
be male mostly so what if we skewed it a
little bit like yeah we should know it
should be more or less equal so let's
just cut out a little bit of the data
that we know is skewed or something like
that
can we do it so in my personal opinion
yes because we have a silver we have a
status quo established in our society
that isn't necessarily fair so I I don't
see much of a problem in us trying to
make it fairer kind of lower down the
Icarus for example okay it's not 100%
true we're pushing a little bit but I
truly believe that
it can have positive effects in our
society because let's get certain genes
for example we are often often seen when
we look for I don't know nurse only
women
doctor only men and how much of this is
because it is as it is and how much this
can change when we have equal
representation and then when children
and teenagers will make their research
to put it on schoolwork or something
they have equal representation and then
say ok it's I am seeing women in this
professional just as I'm seeing men this
professional and we are kind of
reflecting this forward you know faith
financier alright thank you again
[Applause]